we have what's new and f-sharp with
Philip so Philip now is it Philip or
fillers it's like dr. same with a
British accent Philip no you could say
his majesty Philip that like I do normal
like that yeah well welcome
alright King Seth thank you hi my name
is Philip Carter I look in different
cameras and I'm here to talk today about
what's new with f-sharp because I work
on f-sharp and other net stuff on the
f-sharp and Donna team so yeah I want to
give a little bit of an overview first
the first is I want to give a slight
recap of F sharp 4.6 which we released
earlier this year and we've been making
some improvements on sort of leading up
to the f-sharp 4.7 release so I think
it's good to sort of talk about that
sort of stuff you know right before
talking about the brand new stuff I then
want to talk about brand new stuff with
f-sharp 4.7 and then I want to talk
about brand new new stuff like even
newer than the brand new stuff and
f-sharp preview bits which were actually
shipping alongside f-sharp 4.7 is
actually the first time that we're doing
this so it's pretty radical so after our
4.6 this was released earlier this year
with Visual Studio 2019 however we've
been making incremental improvements
especially to the tools since that
release so I've started 4.6 wasn't
really kind of this thing that came out
and you know now it's done it's
something that's been continually
improved upon and really the big pieces
there were just performance so what you
see here are two issues on our github
repository that are related the tooling
performance and interestingly enough
this tooling work is not necessarily in
the tools so much as it is in the
compiler and so what I mean by that is
the f-sharp compiler has been around for
a while and it's very well optimized for
you know compiling code right you take
some code you run the compiler against
it you get an assembly you can run that
assembly it's very good at doing that
sort of stuff however what some people
may not necessarily know is that the
f-sharp compiler that we use to actually
compile your code is also the same
compiler that's hosted inside of Visual
Studio inside of Visual Studio code and
bs for mac that's
stuff so you know the same code paths
that we have internally that take your
code in a minute assembly are you know
the ones that are run when you're asking
for things like intelligence or tooltips
or things like that and one of the
problems that we identified was things
that were very highly optimized for you
know just a single past compilation
producing assembly we're not necessarily
optimized when in a long like a long
live process sort of like a server
process you can imagine inside of
tooling and so as you can see there's a
whole bunch of problems that were here
that are all checked off because they're
all issues that were fixed and the end
result is just massive performance
improvements in all of your tooling
especially if you have really large
solutions so this is something that came
out with half strat 4.6 but it's also
been continually improving and so I like
to think of F sharp 4.6 is this thing
that you know over the course of
multiple releases have just has just
gotten a lot better
leading up to the F sharp 4.7 release so
the other thing that I that was sort of
mentioned there with after at 4.6 was
the anonymous records feature and I want
to show that in visual studio code just
a little bit before I get into the new
stuff so moving over here into visual
studio code which I will point out is
using the official F sharp plug-in known
as eyen ID which has about 1.4 million
downloads now it's running f-sharp 4.6
it's actually the f-sharp 427 compiler
but I'm just showing f-sharp 4.6 right
now and I'm gonna show you a little bit
about anonymous records
so for f-sharp programmers out there who
are familiar with records you know them
very well as these types that you can
declare upfront they're just you know
really neat little data holders and you
know you can do a whole bunch of
different stuff with them and then a lot
of f-sharp programmers are very used to
tuples where you can just sort of ad hoc
kind of on the fly when you need it
group some stuff together and then you
know do whatever you want to do with it
but with the problem with tuples is you
know you don't you don't get you know as
good a tooling support as you do with
records right you can't rename labels it
does it's not able to track things as
well and and that's just sort of
inherent with you know tuples being a
bit more of a lightweight thing and
records kind of being this okay well I
declare the type I'm going to
instantiate this type I'm going to use
it in this particular way
and a lot of people want something in
between they want some of the tooling
support that you get with records
however they also once sort of that ad
hoc you know hey on the fly I just want
to construct a few things and do some
stuff with it and then later on they may
actually decide hey that ad hoc stuff
that I constructed I want to pull that
out into a real type declaration and you
can't really do that with tuples today
so that's or one of the primary reasons
why anonymous Records exists so walking
through the code here we've got this
function it's called get circle stats
takes in our radius which is a float and
you'll notice if I hover over here
there's there's kind of a big tooltip
here saying get circle stats given a
radius produces you know this little
bracket thingy and that's an anonymous
record type that's that's a it you know
used to notice there's the little
bracket in the bar regular records don't
have the the bar anonymous records do
that's sort of the main way that you
distinguish them in syntax and so I got
the area the diameter the circumference
just normal math stuff and then I
construct some stats about that about
the circle or that was that is defined
by the radius that I was given right
it's got a diameter it's got an area of
the circle in Scotts circumference and
so when I actually call that code I can
get a you know my little radius value
this case it's 3.0 I got the circle
stats and then I can print the values
out so if this were a tuple if I were to
do something like this you know there's
there's nothing stopping me from doing
something like this right just sort of
returning a tuple and and then Deacon
decomposing the tuple at the call site
and then calling it there but you know I
have to construct the names at the call
site every time to get access to stuff
and especially if I have like a lot of a
lot of stuff that that you know has like
meaningful names that I want to change
over time you know maybe I don't like
the name on I want to refactor it a
little bit I can't really do that with
tuples and in fact now if I want to
refactor this I can just go ahead and do
that right here I can go rename and I'll
just call that area because area of the
circle is a bit redundant and boom it
automatically changes it I don't have to
go and find the name that I constructed
from the tuple that I got back and then
also rename that I can just do it on the
fly
so this is you know pretty much what you
can already do with record types like I
could have defined a circle stats type
as a record upfront and then constructed
an instance one of those but what if I
wanted to sort of ad hoc group the
radius value with these other values
that I have here well you know again
that sort of thing I could do something
like this I could go you know let the
group is you know I could tuple I could
go radius and I could go circle stats
and there we go this is sort of a
typical thing that you would do in F
sharp but you know again what if I want
it but I want like you know an actual
radius value that I could then refactor
over time
that's where anonymous records really
shine here so I'll call this more circle
stats and I'm going to take my circle
stats value that I have here and I'm
gonna use copy and update syntax that
you would normally have with regular
record however instead of just copying
the record into a new you know with a
new value I'm going to throw a new field
on there so I'm going to say circle
stats with radius equals radius and now
print this out I could go more circle
stats dot radius and there we go I have
that and that that sort of gives you the
power of being able to ad hoc group
things up like you would with tuples but
also get some of the niceness that you
have with records now there's a little
bit more that you can do with anonymous
records I want to show just sort of
briefly if you're doing type
declarations a bit of code here but so
you may have something like a
discriminated Union type you know an
employee could either be an engineer a
manager or an executive and so you know
but I may want to have a bunch of data
associated with each of those types now
a very common way to do that sort of
thing is to is is to do something like
this right I could could have a manager
type here
there we go I didn't spell it correctly
and so I may want to have a record that
holds the data and have you know that
sort of grow over time but you know if I
want to group things up in a way that's
convenient I need to use recursive type
declarations which that's nice if you
want to sound like you're really fancy
to your co-workers or something but what
it actually means you have to write more
code and you have to sort of declare
something as like a big ol unit together
now I could tuple these up I could have
you know like a name is a string and
then I could say you know reports is an
employee list but then that's a tuple
instead of a record type and what if I
want to have a record type well now I
have to actually make it you know the
the name manager well with anonymous
records you don't have to do that at all
there's you'll notice there's less code
here there's no need for a recursive
type declaration and that's because you
know I've just sort of in line to the
record here so again you get sort of the
benefit of both worlds here of you know
having sort of an ad hoc grouping of
values but in this case in a type
declaration and that's pretty powerful
for anonymous records so moving on after
our 4.6 it's great we release it we made
some improvements some improvements
they're actually shipping in the vs 16.3
release but the new stuff is f-sharp 4.7
and the F chart preview that we shipped
alongside it now this I think I'm a
little bit more excited about mostly
because we just shipped it yesterday it
includes a few things mainly language
versioning in the compiler itself which
I'll talk about a bits implicit yields
and some relaxed syntax which is I'll go
over that a little bit the high-level
bit here is it just makes your code
easier to write sort of less surprises
things are a bit more consistent with
other things in the language and then I
start preview has some some new features
that I'll show off here so I'm gonna
show off some of this stuff but instead
of es code I'm gonna hop over to visual
studio here the old big IDE and we'll
get going so I have a console project
here named it f-sharp 4 7 this is done a
core project and I want to sort of
demonstrate what implicit yields mean by
taking you from a compile error to
working code
so as you may have noticed there's a red
squiggle here right I can generate a
sequence with a range expression I can
go okay give me from 1 to 10 that's a
new sequence awesome cool well what if I
just want a sequence comprised of one
two and three all right well now it says
invalid object sequence or record
expression that's what that's that's
that's pretty weird now you can actually
do this in lists and arrays but you
can't do it with sequences which is kind
of weird in fact you have to sprinkle
this keyword everywhere this yield
keyword and you know especially if
you're a beginner to the language this
is not very fun it's it's not very
discoverable but the error message
doesn't tell you anything about it and
you know we could improve the error
message but you know we figured we might
as well improve the language instead of
you know fix the root problem not
necessarily just make the the
diagnostics a little bit better we also
have this function called get days of
week that produces a list and the same
problem actually shows itself in things
that are not sequences if you decide to
start conditionally generating things so
in this case I want to generate Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday but if
include weekend is true I also want to
give back Saturday and Sunday now
there's just a bunch of stuff here this
is a horrible error message frankly now
again I could put in the yield and yes
it turns out I have to put yields in
absolutely every single spot and that's
the only way to get rid of that error
message at least that's the way that
things were up until f sharp four point
seven now if I open up my project file
you'll notice that I have this land
version property up here and I've
explicitly set it to four point six
which is the the older shouldn't say
older the one that I just talked about
here and so I'm just going to comment
that out because this is a new project
and so new projects implicitly use the
latest Lang version so you don't have to
always set it yourself and if I go back
to this file
voila all of the error messages are gone
because all of these yields can now be
made implicit now granted I can if I'm
really in love with these yields I can
add them all back and the compiler is
totally fine with that so this is
backwards compatible you know there's
there's there's no issue with doing that
the old way but we think that a lot of
people are gonna like doing this you
know the new way once they're not short
four-point-seven so speaking of doing
things a little bit better we got a
wonderful feature that was contributed
by by one of our community members his
name is Gustavo Lyon and there's a
couple things I want to point out here
so first you can declare you know this
is how you declare an object in F sharp
and we require an explicit this pointer
for members you know I could name this
anything I want I can name it this or
self or something like that there's just
sort of a convention of the language now
you'll notice this is grayed out and
that's because I'm not actually using
self I'm not really doing anything you
know recursively with this class so what
typical F sharp programmers would do is
they'd say okay well you know I'm just
gonna put an underbar there that
indicates that you know that it doesn't
really matter the this pointer but you
had to do a double underbar and that's
because what you could perhaps be a
viewed and as a bug and the parser sort
of had this little weird quirk where you
had to put a double underbar instead of
a single underbar whereas in pretty much
everywhere else in the language if you
want to just discard something or say I
don't really care what the name is you
can just have a single underbar so this
was fixed by Deus by Gustavo Lyon and
it's a wonderful little change it's just
kind of one of those things that you
know it's these little paper cuts that
can get you sometimes when you're
working in a language especially if it's
a new language and you're not quite
familiar with its idioms and this is
just one of those things that cleans up
some of those paper cuts and the little
code fixer here knows to prefix it well
in this case it actually prefix it with
underscore that's one of the options
that you have the code fixer will also
actually do the same there so the
tooling is also up to date with that
particular feature speaking of
relaxation this part of the demo is
actually it's really nothing it's just
looking at the code and the reason why I
think that's important is because if
you've been using f-sharp prior to
f-sharp 4.7 you know that you would not
be able to write this code today you
would have to tab everything over like
this you would have to align this B and
this D with this a and that was the only
way that you
get the compiler to actually accept this
particular declaration of the
constructor that you have here and
frankly that's just kind of annoying so
we just made it so you got to indent
over one and the same thing applies to
static methods in this case so again
before you had to move all of these over
so that they were perfectly aligned with
the first parameter that you laid out
now they don't have to be they just need
to have one indentation level over so
that the compiler can understand that
these are referring to the method that
you are declaring right here so that's
kind of you know aside from a whole
bunch of bug fixes and more perfect
performance improvements that's kind of
what's going on for a short 40.7 but
let's talk a little bit about f-sharp
preview because that's where things
start to get a little bit fancy here so
I'm going to go back to my project file
and I'm going to uncomment out this lang
version flag because this is something
I'm going to have to actually do now if
I want to use preview features I'm going
to clear out 4.6 I'm going to type
preview so save that
open up this file called name of and
you'll notice that there's no red
squiggles and that's because we've sort
of activated the preview mode so
internally the way that we do things in
the compiler is whenever there's a
feature that's implemented now it's
associated with a feature flag and then
that feature flag is associated with a
given release of the language so in this
case name of this has the name of
feature flag and that feature flag is
associated with the preview release of
the f-sharp compiler so what that
actually means is if you set your Langan
to be preview you will get everything
that's associated with that internally
one of them being named of so going back
to the code here this is just sort of
some basic usage that's you could you
know it's pretty self-explanatory right
I have a function it's called combined
lengths I take two strings str1 and str2
and I want to dot and get the length of
both of them and combine them pretty
straightforward I just want to make sure
that they're not no before I actually do
that and in this case I'm going to raise
an argument no exception and then I want
to pass the name of the parameter there
so in this case before I would have to
do this or or you know out there we go
I would have to do something like that
and if I change the name of the
parameter I would have to know to go
back into the string literal and also
change it that you don't have to do if
you're on the F chart preview anymore
you can just take the name of everything
that you're working with and that's
pretty great this is you know this has
been around in c-sharp for a while and
this is something that's been highly
requested by the F chart community for a
number of years it's extremely powerful
if you're doing a lot of logging of
parameters and different values and you
want to sort of log you know okay this
thing which was you know nested and this
thing and nested in this thing and you
want to lay it all out and get it into
strings you can refactor with ease and
know that you don't have to actually
update anything else from there so just
to show a little bit more of what you
can do with name of I have a module with
a function and then I have the system
namespace up there so I'm actually
taking the name of the namespace so you
could do that if you'd like I'm taking
the name of a module that I declared and
I'm taking the name of an explicitly a
qualified function you know m dot F
that's the name of the actual function
that'll take the name and
just for kicks I can go let name of name
of and I can take name of name of itself
now this is probably not very useful for
anyone but you know it just happened to
be something that was enabled by the
feature and so it's kind of no reason
not to keep it so we have it and it's
fun so the next one the next feature
that shipping in the F sharp preview is
opening of static classes so let me go
up right here so a static class is you
know as this just got a bunch of static
methods on it or static members or maybe
some constants things like that one of
the best examples of a static class is
the system math class and historically
you and fear and F sharp you would have
to go math dot you know you would have
to explicitly qualify math dot whatever
you want to use to be able to actually
use it but now you can just actually
open this thing and you know if you were
to do this an F chart four point seven
or I've start four point six you did not
have the preview turned on you would
actually get an error saying that there
is no namespace called system or not
math and that's because it's a class
it's not a namespace and so what that
means is I could just call sine of pi
rather than math dot sine of math dot PI
it's the sort of thing that is really
handy if you're working with the math
namespace and other libraries that do
this sort of thing where they put this
kind of functionality behind static
classes and this is also helpful for
f-sharp programmers who want to create
dsls that use method overloads just like
just like you can do a little bit in
c-sharp and you can actually declare
those an f-sharp today because as it
turns out a static class is it's it's
not really like a real thing it's it's
an abstract sealed class in net and so
you just create a type that is both
abstract and sealed and you give it some
static members in this case I gave it l
m n o and P and you know then you can
open this class when you have the
feature enabled and you can just call
them like that I don't have to
explicitly specify my static class l of
my static class dot m of my static class
you know and so on
this is something that we're pretty
excited about especially with some of
the focus on working with machine
learning frameworks that we've been
doing
lately because a lot of these frameworks
for dotnet are using static classes to
sort of pack these method overloads
behind there but you know have it be
sort of a functional interface and this
will play very nicely with that sort of
stuff in the future so that just about
rounds outs after at 4.7 and the F sharp
preview
so as a quick summary here after at 4.6
we shipped anonymous records we've made
improvements to those and the tooling
for them over time it works pretty much
everywhere and there's been tons of
performance improvements in the compiler
and the tools since it was released all
the way up until now and also including
this release with a sharp 4.7 after at
four point seven once I fix the spelling
error here I like to think of it it just
sort of makes things easier for you as
an f-sharp programmer it cleans up a lot
of little things and especially if
you're using you know these yields a lot
like if you're you know writing web
sharper or Fable code which uses lists
and as sort of like an HTML style DSL
something like that this makes it a lot
easier and then the Lang version support
allows you to sort of bump up to a
preview try some stuff out give us a lot
of feedback get access to those features
wait earlier before they actually ship
and then I start preview is all about
features right now we're just going to
keep building features and shipping
features starting now pretty much all
the way until the middle of next year
before we start stabilizing for the.net
5 release so if you want to get started
with an f-sharp 4.7 there's just a
single link you got to go to you just go
to a kms
this takes us to the f-sharp home page
on the dotnet website and if you go
there there's just a big old button that
says get started it'll take you to
download the latest nat sdk and you can
do that you'll have F sharp 4.7 already
available and then you'll be able to get
off and go running with it